the head of the Senate Judiciary
Committee is demanding answers tonight
about what he described as quote what
amounts to a coup against the president
by top Justice Department officials
chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge has details tonight
could even Catherine Thank You Brendon
good evening the letter to attorney
General William Barr seeks all records
including the so-called McCabe memos
drafted by the former acting FBI
director the Republican chairman of the
Senate Judiciary Committee Lindsey
Graham said he is formally investigating
allegations that Andrew McCabe Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein among
others discussed secretly recording the
President and invoking the 25th
amendment quote the committee is deeply
concerned with these discussions and
whether they essentially indicate the
two of the highest ranking law
enforcement officials in the United
States were discussing what amounts to a
coup against the president also today
unsealed records from a defamation case
show how the anti-trump dossier was
circulated before and after the 2016
election the court records confirmed
that David Kramer then an aide to the
late Senator John McCain gave the
dossier to BuzzFeed news as well as
about a dozen reporters Kramer told the
court he was singled out by the dossiers
author former British spy Christopher
Steele to Lang credibility to the
Democrat funded opposition research the
project was run by glenn simpson's
fusion gps quote i think they felt a
senior republican was better to be the
recipient of this rather than a democrat
because if it were a democrat i think
the view was that it would have been
dismissed as a political attack the
FBI's former counterterrorism
intelligence chief bill pre-snap also
filed the declaration confirming the FBI
got the dossiers first 33 pages from
mccain in december 2016 that the FBI was
already receiving the memos from other
sources pre-snap
also confirmed President Obama was
briefed on the unverified dossier by
senior intelligence officials including
then DNI James clapper 10 days before
the inauguration Bret captain thank you